[Music]
hey guys it's Jonah here every single
day we make lots of food decisions on
what to eat where to eat how much to eat
and even who to eat with 90% of the food
decisions we make a habit base so
perhaps you are trying to make changes
to your current eating habits the in
healthier it better it last and also to
make better food decisions so I want to
share with you 10 really simple food
hacks to trick your brain into eating
less without feeling deprived or needing
to make drastic changes to your current
eating habits first downsize your plate
downsize your portion both these bowls
have the exact same amount of muesli
research has shown that if you eat from
a larger plate you're more likely to
pile on more food to fill up the plate
so swap for smaller bowls plates and
utensils to eat less your eyes will
trick your brain into thinking that you
are having more contrast the color of
your plates and food both these plates
have the exact same amount of rice if
you serve it on a white plate you may
end up eating 22% more than on a dark
play so if you want to eat less the
trick is to select plates that have a
high contrast to the food on the
contrary if you want to eat more greens
try serving them on a green plate drink
tall both these glasses have the exact
same amount of liquid visually the tall
thin glass appears to hold more than the
short glass so limit bad liquid calories
such as sodas and alcohols by serving
them in tall glasses you will be
drinking 20% less buy small packs
instead of a large pack when you have a
packet of snack in front of you no
matter what the size is chances are you
will aim to finish it in one sitting
opt for smaller packs and eat less if
you can buy smaller packets and then
divide them into smaller containers
never is directly from the packet drink
water first when you think you feel
hungry before you reach for that
chocolate bar to fill you up
drink water first
chances are you might just be dehydrated
instead of actually being hungry drink
water or have a light broth-based a
vegetable soup before your meal it will
fill you up and you will eat about 20
percent less per main meal keep food out
of sight if you're a snacker this next
trick is for you if a food is nearby and
you can visually see it I'm sure you
will reach for it eat it even if you're
not hungry choose to store biscuits and
treats in a non-transparent container
and keep them in the food cabinet or
drawers if you don't see it you won't
think of it and you won't eat it leave
evidence behind don't be too excited to
keep your plate clean after eating
previous experiments have shown that
when we have no evidence of the food we
have consumed we eat 28% more so give
yourself visual clues to help you track
how much you have eaten especially if
you're eating out or Ana buffet leave
those trash by your side to keep you in
check practice proper plating method
when you look at a plate remind yourself
that a healthy portion should be half
vegetables a quarter of lean protein and
a quarter of whole grains this plating
method will automatically lower the
overall calorie consumption increase
your total fiber intake
hence keeping you fool without
overeating divide the food on your plate
nowadays most restaurants tend to serve
huge portions to keep their customers
happy a full meal can sometimes contain
more than 1200 calories to avoid
overeating divide your meal divide that
mountain of food into to eat now pile
and to bring home pile once you have
finished that to eat now pile keilly ask
the waiter to pack the leftovers
immediately if you leave your food on
the table and continue chatting with
your friends chances are you will
continue eating and finish the entire
plate and find
limit distractions during mealtime if
you eat with distractions your body may
not register the food you've eaten and
you may end up eating more so turn off
the TV put your laptop and smartphone
away while you eat engage with your
senses its dead look smell your food and
taste every bite and for those of you
who work in an office consider taking
your lunch break away from your desk so
I really hope you've enjoyed this video
and found it to be useful building a
lifestyle of healthy habits is long-term
so start by practicing these 10 simple
food hacks and over time you will subtly
influence your mind and behavior to eat
less and also lose weight so which is
your favorite mind trick let me know in
the comments below like this video share
it and subscribe to my youtube channel
for more fun and informative food tips
do also check out the video links in my
description box as I believe they will
help you to understand healthy eating in
more detail all the best
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
[Music]